The Joe Rogan Experience to go back to
where we started today
there's nothing that's worse for
parenting than there's nothing that's
worse for parenting than parents of
young children being using drugs whether
a drug is alcohol or cannabis or you
know or meth or heroin it is terrible
for parenting I mean it leads to abuse
neglect it leads to Poverty it leads to
terrible outcomes and I don't know how
you stopped that but one of the things
when you consider whether you're gonna
set up a world where drug use is sort of
a loud slash encourage slash
commercialized is the effect on young
kids it's a really good question and I
you know as a person who believes
that freedom is one of the most
important things I also come from a
perspective where you know I'm in a
different place in life than I was when
I was 20 and what would I be like when I
was 20 if heroin was legal what would I
be like if cocaine was legal what would
I have done and that there's a there's a
reality that if you open the gates now
and you say now all of these drugs are
legal we're going to regulate them and
the way to stop fentanyl coming in in
these tainted cocaine is to sell pure
cocaine and it'd actually be better for
everybody I I don't I don't believe that
I truly don't believe it I don't think
the problem is the tainted drugs I think
the problem is that drugs just eat
people I think there's both of those
things but what I was about to say is if
you did do that you would undeniably
have a certain amount of people that are
going to get addicted that never would a
certain amount of people that were going
to lose their lives that never would a
certain amount of violent actions car
accidents people on meth and heroin and
drugs and Coke and they're going to do
wild [__] yep and you know people are
super unpredictable when they're [__]
up on drugs
and you're going to have real problems
and that that's also true but you know
would more people do it if it was legal
I think you're right I think more people
would try it but eventually not
so we just have to sacrifice a whole
generation to people learn you ever go
to Europe and and see like the like kids
are allowed to drink wine in Italy sure
and so they don't they're like they're
instances of alcoholism and it's not a
big deal to them for us it's a big deal
like I remember the first time I got
drunk with my friends we were listening
to Led Zeppelin
this is my friend Jimmy and it was like
it was like [__] we're like 15 years old
14 15 years old and I I got sick in a
cab like the whole thing like yeah like
but it was getting alcohol was crazy
yeah if you live in Europe it's normal
like they they they accused they get
their kids acclimated to it like you
don't let them drink but they're allowed
to have a sip of alcohol have a little
it's not that big a deal right don't
think of it as like some forbidden fruit
that you can't wait to get to to get
[__] up
even with you know adults we know that
even with adults that have you know
reasonable ways of approaching every
other aspect of her life some of them
can't have a drink that's right they
can't they can't do it they get [__]
gerbilized and they're gone you know you
know those guys yes of course those are
real people too and what do we do about
that and it's a good question but it's a
question that unfortunately
there's so many pros and cons of both
sides and the con of both sides is crazy
because you're empowering a gigantic
criminal Enterprise that is yes that's
crazy and that was Prohibition that was
the thing that was going on in America
they didn't stop people from drinking
whiskey but they stopped them from
drinking good whiskey they were making
moonshine and you know that was what
Nascar was created yes yeah they were
trying to run away from boys out yeah
yeah they developed hot rod cars to run
away from cops and they said you know we
should race these [__] and they
just kind of [__] police tracks in a
circle yes I mean that's literally how
NASCAR started it's it's kind of amazing
but it's just
there's no real there's no one perfect
answer there's no one thing we say you
know what if we do this we'll have zero
deaths and everyone's going to be
peaceful and the world's going to be a
Utopia there's no answer like that no
but here and I'm not suggesting this
okay but you if you have a regime that
is really strict on drug use you don't
have much drug use I mean I'm talking
about I'm talking about like you know
like like Saudi Arabia yeah you know if
you're if you're cutting people's hands
off and and that would never fly here
and I don't think it's a good idea it's
definitely not but this idea that like
you can't culturally and societally
lower the levels of drug use is not true
you can it's just the question of the
price you pay right but that isn't that
the thing about like peace as well like
as long as you're willing to have like
like who was the was it the
was the who's the was it the president
of the Philippines that was okay yes yes
yes yes I mean yes I bet that had an
impact yes
yes I mean I wouldn't recommend it but I
bet it worked to a certain extent that's
right no it's but uh so there's just
this idea the drug legalization Lobby
has very successfully argued that
basically you can't manage the amount of
drug use in a society you just have to
manage the consequences and that is
demonstrably untrue here here's another
like drinking and driving used to be
pretty Society acceptable and now it's
not acceptable I mean people start still
sometimes do it but levels are way down
have you ever seen that video from when
they first started telling people you
can't have an open beer in your car no
see if you can find that video Jamie I
think it's from the 1970s and then this
lady's like basically we're becoming
communists
and this guy's like you work all day
it'd be nice you could have a beer on
your way home like it's crazy these
people are advocating for openly
drinking in their cars that's right you
can change that behavior in attitudes
well that's a wild one that's a wild one
that people want to be able to just
[__] booze it up while they're
driving listen to this driving here is
viewed by some as downright on Democrats
it's got to get in common this one a
fellow King and I put in A Hard Day's
Work put in 11 12 hours a day and then
getting your truck in the lace running
one or two beers
where you can't drink when you want a
baby yeah wear a seat belt when you're
driving and
pretty soon we're going to become this
country
that's when Trump got its first light
bulb
I think I could be president
[Laughter]
that guy I didn't even like his accent I
didn't even I underdid it yes he was
over the top but the baby next to the
baby right there that's how you tastes
to carry babies around put them in there